[Musique]
bonjour Denis Saint-Léger
favorables à la Russie qui assurent que
Moscou développe des armes de nouvelles
génération pour combattre en Ukraine
avec des images à qu'il présente comme
exclusive exclusif du front même aux
dires de certaines publications une
minute d'image que l'on va découvrir
ensemble on y voit tantôt des chars
tantôt aussi des missiles donc sur plus
d'une minute des images présentées comme
exclusive comme du matériel de dernière
génération particulièrement innovant
particulièrement performant cette
information elle a été diffusée
essentiellement par des comptes prorus
donc provenant d'Afrique francophone
d'Afrique de l'Ouest des images
exclusives donc je vous le disais au
dire en tout cas de ces internautes qui
présentent les chars les plus dangereux
au monde vous voyez que cette
publication a tout de même cumulé plus
de 500 000 vues rien que sur Facebook ce
qui est présenté un comme
exclusiféressant est en fait une
séquence ancienne à Antony effectivement
et ça on l'apprend grâce à la recherche
d'image inversée la fameuse en
l'occurrence via Yandex le moteur de
recherche russe on retrouve les images
en faisant cette recherche que l'on voit
ici c'est une occurrence qui va nous
intéresser elle est ici et on va
retrouver les mêmes images dans un
reportage de la chaîne locale de
Sébastopol HTC et vous le voyez ce
reportage du 17 octobre 2019 Sébastopol
qui est sous giron russe depuis 2014
donc ça n'a rien à voir avec le conflit
actuel que nous dit ce reportage et bien
il s'agit bien de l'entrée en service de
des derniers systèmes de missiles
anti-aérien
Mkm Buck m3 pardon on va en savoir plus
lorsque l'on fait une recherche Google
non plus Yandex donc mais Google cette
fois ci avec les mots clés en russe donc
missile anti-aérien Buc m3 et on va la
cantonner cette recherche à cette
période toute l'année 2019 et on
retrouve la vidéo originale en
l'occurrence elle est ici sur la chaîne
Youtube du ministère de la Défense russe
et vous le voyez elle date bien du 16
octobre 2019 et il s'agissait bien
effectivement de l'entrée en service de
nouveaux missiles des armes qui à
l'époque était novatrices mais rien à
voir donc avec la guerre qui sévit
actuellement en Ukraine dans ce même
esprit un de surenché avec glorification
des comptes pro russe partage des images
sensi illustrer la destruction de la
base ukrainienne de descente Tony là
encore ce sont des comptes prorus
essentiellement basé en Afrique de
l'Ouest on a pu voir par exemple
récemment ces images ou même ces vidéos
censées montrer la destruction par des
drones kamikazes du QG opérationnel sud
des forces armées ukrainiennes à Odessa
alors une attaque qui est bien réelle
puisque elle remonte au 24 septembre
d'ailleurs le commandement concerné s'en
faisait les causes sur sa page Facebook
et cette attaque a d'ailleurs tué de
civils mais là l'image que l'on a vu
dans la publication virale absolument à
rien à voir avec Odessa puisque à défaut
d'être à Odessa on est à Rungis au sud
de Paris en région parisienne donc et on
est bien cette fois toutefois pardon le
24 septembre le 25 même rappelez-vous de
ce spectaculaire incendie que l'on a pu
voir dans un des entrepôts de fruits et
légumes de Rungis et bien la vidéo
originale on la retrouve sur Twitter on
a même les coordonnées géographiques qui
nous sont données de l'endroit où ça a
été
tourné en tout cas
aperçu et d'ailleurs si vous faites une
comparaison entre la photo virale que
l'on voit ici et la photo Twitter de la
vidéo originale vous retrouvez
exactement le même cadrage et les mêmes
angles de prise de vue et cela va nous
être confirmé grâce à la géolocalisation
ici une capture d'écran de la séquence
général et ici regardez bien les prises
de vue via Google Maps vous reconnaissez
l'inscription mandar donc du nom de ces
halles de fruits et légumes qui ont
brûlé on la distingue ici mais on
retrouve également le panneau que l'on
voit ici la bretelle d'accès
autoroutière ici et puis et également
cette façade de bâtiments que l'on
retrouve aisément ici incendie à Rungis
qui n'a donc rien à voir avec au dessin
bienvenue à Régis merci beaucoup Anthony
c'était un faux intox avec Anthony
Saint-Léger restez avec nous on se
retrouve dans trois minutes pour un
nouveau journal dans Paris direct
[Musique]